she got really like stressed out she was
like Mommy you're fat I try not to take
it personal because I'm like super into
fitness but I'm like um
am I Serena Williams getting shade from
daughter Olympia as she prepares to
welcome her second child I've always
wanted to be a mom it's so natural for
me looks like five-year-old Olympia is
pretty excited about the big news
Serena revealed that she was expecting
earlier this month with her baby bump on
full display at the Met Gala
today at the Met is such a big moment
for me
I am revealing to the world that I am
pregnant I'm expecting my second child
which is exciting but it turns out
Little Olympia only heard the news just
before Serena shared it with the rest of
the world so the big reveal will be at
the mat and then before we leave I'll
tell Olympia the reason I haven't told
her is because she can't keep a secret
yeah it's definitely not easy are you
still gonna help us keep it a secret for
one more day okay one more day yeah
after today you can tell everybody
Serena also revealed her true
inspiration behind this year's Met Gala
look this is the look that I'm gonna
show my daughter or my son when they're
born one day they'll look back and
they'll see this is how mommy expressed
herself and told everyone that she was
pregnant with you and you want this
moment to be totally iconic and totally
fresh but yet really special working
method is real it's so real but at my
priorities in Olympia is that I'm never
a day without Olympia like she's my
priority and every day I like need to be
home with her because I don't I don't
want to miss any moments with her I love
her so much and you know it's just we
have a great little family going on yeah
and that little family is continuing to
grow just like Serena hinted at wanting
in the past they always and I found my
wife one makes you want to yeah that's
definitely true I definitely want to God
willing
um but right now I'm
gonna wait and see what happens
foreign